We are on problem 15.
A store charges $28 for
a type of sweater.
This price is 40% more than it
costs the store to buy one of
these sweaters.
So $28 is 40% more than
what it costs.
So that equals the cost plus
40% of the cost. Right?
0.4 is the same thing
as 40%, right?
It's the cost plus 40%
of cost. That's
what 40% more means.
Another way, you could kind of
immediately say, well, that's
just the same thing as 1.4 times
the cost. And that's
kind of shorthand.
You might immediately go to the
step, 1.4 times the cost
OK, let's see what it says.
At the end-of-season sale, store
employees can purchase
any remaining sweaters at 30%
off the store's cost. So the
sale price-- let me call that
s-- is equal to the cost minus
0.3 times the cost. Right?
30% off of the cost. This is 30%
of the cost. You take that
off of the original cost. And
that is equal to, of course,
0.7 times the cost. This
is the sale price.
It's 0.7 times the cost. How
much would it cost an employee
to purchase a sweater of
this type at this sale?
So let's see.
So how much would it cost?
So we could figure
out what the cost
is from this equation.
We have 28 is equal to 1.4 times
the cost. Cost is equal
to 28 divided by 1.4.
I just divide both
sides by 1.4.
I switched them around.
Let's see, 28 divided by
14 would be 2, right?
28 divided by 1.4 is 20.
So that makes sense.
And you could go
the other way.
40% more than 20.
40% of 20 is 8.
You add 8 to 20, you get 28.
So that's right.
The cost is $20.
And now the sale is 0.7 times
the cost. So sale is equal to
0.7 times the cost. And
that equals what?
20 times 0.7 is $14.
Because 20 times 7 is 140.
You have one decimal
place, $14.
So that is choice B.
Next problem.
Problem 16.
And then we're done
with this section.
In rectangle ABCD-- let me
draw rectangle ABCD, even
though they haven't.
OK, rectangle-- whoops--
A, B, C, D.
In rectangle ABCD, E is
the midpoint of BC.
So let me draw E.
So this distance is equal
to that distance.
If the area of quadrilateral
ABED is 2/3, what is the area
of the entire rectangle?
Fascinating.
So they're making another
quadrilateral within this.
And I'll just draw it.
Let me do it in another color.
So they're saying the area
of this thing, ABED.
Area of that thing is 2/3.
And so they want you to
figure out the area
of the whole thing.
And so this is just a pure
visualization problem.
Because what I can do is I can
break up this rectangle in a
interesting way.
Let me do it with this
brown color.
If I wanted to break up this
rectangle, I could break it up
into four equal triangles,
right?
You see here, 1, 2, 3, 4.
And how do I know
they're equal?
Because E is the midpoint.
We know that this side is equal
to this side, because E
is the midpoint.
We know that this is equal to
this, which is equal to this.
So we know that all four of
these rectangles are going to
be the same.
Now, they tell us that the
area of three-- of this
rectangle, this rectangle, and
this rectangle-- right?
That's ABED.
They tell us three of the
rectangles-- sorry, three of
the triangles.
Have I been saying rectangles
the whole time?
These are triangles.
ABEA, these are triangles.
So this rectangle is made up
of four equal triangles.
We know that three of the
triangles-- this quadrilateral
here-- three of the
triangles, so I'll
call them three triangles.
So I'll call it 3 times
the area of each
triangle is equal to what?
It is equal to 2/3.
And we know that because they
told us that the area of this
plus this, plus this is 2/3.
This quadrilateral is 2/3.
So what's the area
of each triangle?
The area of each triangle is
going to be 2/3 divided by 3,
which is 2/9, right?
2/3 times 1/3.
Area of each triangle is 2/9.
So what's going to be the area
of this entire rectangle?
Well, it's going to be this
area-- that we just know is
2/3-- plus the area of one
more triangle right here.
Plus the area of
this triangle.
And then we get the
whole rectangle.
So plus 2/9.
And this equals-- let's see,
common denominator is 9.
2/3 becomes 6/9.
And then you have that plus the
2/9, and this becomes 8/9.
And that is choice C.
And we are done.
So this was a pure visualization
problem.
You just had to see that the
area they gave you was three
equal triangles, and they
essentially just want you to
add the fourth onto it
and figure out what
the total area is.
I'll see you in the
next section.